From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is David Cline for the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Civil Rights History Project.
Today is March 1, 2013, and I'm in San Mateo, California.
And today we have the pleasure of speaking with Mildred Pitts Walter Good afternoon.
Good afternoon.
Thank you so much for participating in this project. We really, really appreciate it.
Thank you for inviting me to participate.
So we're going to I'm on just for the record, I'm on channel 2.
I'm Miss Walters on channel 1.
Okay.
And we'll just start right into it.
Okay. So what I'd like you, if we could just start, if you could tell me a little bit about where you are raised and your family.
I was born in Louisiana in 1922.
And my mother and father were together for a while.
And when Long-Bell Lumber Company left Louisiana, my father was working with them in Mississippi.
And my mother was still in Louisiana.
So I grew up in a place called De Ridder, Louisiana, between Lake Charles and Shreveport in Southwest Louisiana.
I went to a hot-finished board, God-pairish high school, where the only new book I ever had was the history of the Negro.
By Carter G. Woodson.
All the other books we had had pages torn out, or marked up.
But...
Can you describe the, I'd love to hear a description of the school itself and your teachers.
Well, we were in all black school.
And the school was finally a pretty nice building.
Before we had the new school, we were in churches and places.
And finally, we had a school with a principal who could do electricity and heat.
And so we got lights and rather than lamps.
This was all in the 30s and 40s.
And all of our teachers were African-American.
At that time, we were Negroes.
We all were Negroes.
And they were really wonderful teachers.
And they helped us to know that we were not inferior.
And we took seriously Carter G. Woodson's history that told us about Africa and the nice things about Africa.
And of course, we had the church.
The church was very important because the ministers and the leaders insisted that we hold our heads high.
And we took learning seriously.
And whatever we did, do it with an attitude of excellence.
And to walk and approach those who hated us with humility for humility could not be humiliated.
And we learned that and became really strong.
And I made goals and made choices.
I worked from the time I was seven.
I worked taking care of a little white girl for a while.
And then I worked in a beauty shop, cleaning the beauty shop.
And I worked in homes, cleaning homes.
While also going to school?
While going to high school.
And met some very interesting white people who seemed to appreciate the fact that I wanted not to just do that always.
And there was one woman who came, a camp poke was in Leesville not far from us.
And that was time doing World War II.
And these soldiers were there.
And their wives came.
And one woman came from Ohio.
And she hired me to come and help her.
She insisted that I sit at the table and eat with her.
And I just felt, you know, but she was very nice about it.
We sat and she talked.
And I was a sophomore in college.
And she gave me magazines to read.
And she would talk about what we had read.
And when she left, she said to me that I was the only person that she felt comfortable with in that place.
I wish I could remember her name.
Where was she from?
From somewhere in Ohio.
And I'll tell you later how I learned why the majority of southerners didn't let us eat together.
But she insisted on not doing that.
Well, I went from there to Southern University in Scotland, Bill Louisiana.
And I finished Southern.
Well, while I was there, of course, I came in contact with very interesting leaders,
Mordecai Wyatt Johnson, W.E.B. Du Bois, and all of them came and talked to us and inspired us.
And when I left there in 1944, I knew that I couldn't, well, before that in my senior year,
I went up into the state of Washington, Longview, WA.
And I worked in the shipyards in Longview, WA.
So how did you end up there doing that kind of work?
My sister had gone there.
Her husband had moved there, old back in the thirties.
And she lived in Longview, WA.
And I went there to work in the shipyards to earn enough money to finish Southern.
And I had had a lot of experience in personnel working with the dean of women.
So I applied for a job in personnel at the shipyards and they laughed at me.
It was very highly discriminating, even there during that time of the war.
So what job did you end up doing there?
I ended up cleaning ships, working in gyro rooms and cleaning ships.
And my manager, my supervisor, felt she said, this is not the kind of work for you.
And she tried, but nothing happened.
You often hear about African American women with jobs during the war that last hired first fired.
What kind of experience did you have?
Well, I only wanted to be there for a while.
But the women who worked with me, both black and white, they had children.
And we were on the graveyard ship.
So I came in well rested and they would fall asleep.
And I would awake them when the supervisor was coming.
And they appreciated that.
So you were working alongside white women as well as black women?
White women and black women.
And how was that experience like?
Well, it was a nice experience.
They knew that I was a college student.
And they felt that, you know, I shouldn't be there and should get go back as soon as I could.
And I did.
I went back and graduated at Southern.
And when I graduated with my mother's blessings, I went to LA.
Let me just ask again about Washington.
Was that really your first time outside of the South?
That was my first time out of the South.
And did that do anything to you as far as seeing how things were in another part of the country?
Yes.
African Americans were segregated in that little town.
They all lived together.
They went to the same church.
But they could go to an integrated school.
But they lived in an segregated neighborhood.
But they were very much separated.
They didn't, the kids didn't interchange visits or anything like that.
Even there at that time.
Did that surprise you or did it seem expected?
Do you think at that time for you?
No, I just expected that.
You know, I didn't know what the difference should have.
Well, I felt that it should have been different.
But especially working, I thought that I would be able to work, do something different than cleaning ships.
But I was very lucky that they were finished and didn't have all of that stuff that caused long problems.
Yes.
I was very lucky because what we did, we prepared the ships for sailing.
You know, the first voyage trip.
We prepared them for that.
And of course, we never went on a voyage.
Right.
Very interesting.
I saw the ocean for the first time.
We went to the Pacific Ocean and I was, oh, I thought this must be all the water in the world.
And it was such a nice experience.
Portland, Oregon was a very beautiful city.
Lots of roses.
And my brother-in-law would take me to places to so that we could see Mount,
or that Mount didn't just have the terrible Mount St. Helens was in our back.
We could see it from our back door.
And it had snow then.
Snow on Mount St. Helen all year round.
It looks different now.
I bet after that volcanic action, yes.
So, okay.
Work with the machines a little bit.
So, you graduated and you were saying and then decided to move to us hands.
Yes.
I applied for, well, after having worked in Washington, I knew that I did not have to work
for the amount of money that they were paying in Louisiana for teachers.
And that was the only, I could have gone to work at Camp Polk (later Fort Polk), Louisiana as in the laundry or something like that.
But those were the only jobs for college graduates in Louisiana at that time.
And you either teacher or maintenance person.
So, I applied for a job in Shreveport.
They wanted me to teach high school English and do the library for $50 a month.
And I thought, no.
And I decided that.
And my mother, my mother was a very smart woman.
And she said,
when you go to college,
they wash you down and you change.
And you don't fit
in the place.
And I didn't understand what she was saying.
I didn't understand what she was saying.
But she knew that
at that time they taught us in these places very differently.
And we felt that
we spoke correct English.
And we didn't use the dialect.
Were there others in your family who had gone to college?
Not at that time.
I was the youngest and the first.
How many siblings do you have?
Seven of us.
I had five sisters and one brother.
All of that.
But she gave me her blessing.
And I was very happy that I wanted to achieve.
And now when I am a mother and as old as I am,
I understand what she was saying.
And how that can make a difference
with your parents, especially.
She had wanted me to follow in her footsteps
being a midwife and a healer.
And I didn't want that.
So it's a bit bittersweet?
Yes. She wanted to teach me her methods.
She had a cure for pneumonia before penicillin.
And it was penicillin.
But we didn't know that.
It was definitely penicillin.
When we would put the pigs on a floor, feed them grain,
pure mesh that would get in their hooves and mold.
She would boil that, boil them, and give them the doctor would say
to people who had, I can't help you, go see Mary.
And she would cure them with that tea.
She also used oyster shells, red hot oyster shells and water
cool that for kidney problems.
And they know now that oyster shells have a special medicine
that they use now to cure kidney infections.
She was very, a very smart woman with very little formal education.
How had she learned her art?
I don't know.
I really don't know how she had learned that.
But her mother, she had a sister who was 10 years old
at the end of slavery.
And she was born in 18, in 1890, something new.
So she probably knew how to go and find the herbs and plants.
And she could do that.
She could go and find plants and knew these plants that could serve
as a cure for certain things, and especially for women problems.
Just fascinating.
And so your family saw you off to Los Angeles?
Los Angeles.
Yes.
And I went to Los Angeles.
I knew I went with a high school classmate who had a brother
who was living in Skid Row.
And we went and stayed in a hotel on Fifth Street,
very iffy place in Los Angeles at that time.
But a lot of people were transits were there.
And I went and stayed there a few days.
And then I met a woman on the bus.
And I told her I had come, just come to town.
And I thought there would be a YWCA for black women.
There was not a YWCA there.
And I didn't know what to do.
So she said, well, give me a phone number.
No, we were in Los Angeles.
Yeah.
And if I could just ask you, I forgot to say,
ask you what year that was when you first went.
That was in 1944 when I went to Los Angeles.
Great.
And you were just saying you met a woman on the bus?
Yes.
And what happened?
I was sitting in the back.
And I saw this woman.
And she looked very intelligent and very friendly.
I had been taught that we could trust certain people.
And you can tell who you can trust.
And I went, I got up and went and sat beside her.
And she introduced herself and told me a joke.
When I told her I had just come.
She said, oh, these people are coming in.
Coming into town, she said.
And one day a lady was on the bus.
And she sat beside a person.
And this woman was just coming from the south.
She was eating on the bus.
And the lady said, we don't eat on the bus.
And she asked the woman, how long you been here?
And the woman told us she had been there for many years.
She said, well, when I've been here long as you,
I won't eat on the bus either.
And we had a good laugh.
And I told her my problem that I was on Skid Row
and I didn't want to be there.
And she gave me a phone that said, call me if you decide
that it's not where you want to be.
And when I called her, she said,
I could come and live with her.
And she had been there for many years
and was well known in the community.
And she introduced me to all of these nice people
to my sororities sisters.
And so I was well on the way.
And her name was Mozelle Moore.
Very interesting.
And did you start looking for work then as well?
I found work right away.
And I worked and well, I applied for teaching job.
And of course, there were no black teachers in Los Angeles
at that time.
There was one black high school teacher.
And I was told that I would have to have a California credential,
of course.
So I went back to California State University, Los Angeles, got a credential.
And then I was hired as a teacher.
But first before that, I was hired as a clerk
with the Los Angeles City Schools
as a, in a classified section.
And that, the classified section included people
who didn't have certificates.
There were janitors and clerks.
And so I worked as a clerk in a place
where they gave the tests for classified employees.
And that was very interesting.
And went back to school.
Well, I met my husband and we got married.
And I went back to school and got my credential.
And then I started teaching in elementary school.
So can you tell me, I want to ask about your teaching,
but can you tell me about meeting your husband?
Yes.
I, one of my sorority sisters took me to a Methodist church.
And I remember one evening we were having a meeting
with young people.
And he walked in and I said to her,
he was such an intelligent, looking man.
I said, who is that man?
And she said, oh girl, he has lots of girl friends.
You don't want to get involved with him.
But we spoke and I found out that he had also graduated from seven.
And I met, you know, we met.
And he became sort of interested.
But it was not a love at first sight.
No, it wasn't that.
Because we both were mature.
But we were friends.
And I remember one time I had to do a presentation at the church.
And I didn't have a decent dress.
And I asked him to loan me some money to get a hat and a dress.
And he loaned me the money.
And when I paid him back, he said, well, I wasn't worried
because I knew you didn't want anybody to have anything on you.
And he gave me the money back.
And that's the kind of person he was.
And I remember one time we had a meeting with the students from USC.
And I made the spaghetti and fixed all the food and said the blessing and the prayer.
And he was impressed.
And then we started seriously growing in love.
And we married in 1947.
And was he already involved with CORE at that time?
Yes, he was involved with CORE and had been since 1942.
And he was also involved with another organization called Drew, AM Drew.
And they were working against segregation in hotels and hotels.
Do you know what that stands for?
Drew.
That was a person's name.
It was just an organization.
It was an organization started by that name.
But he was also working with CORE at that time.
But not very, it wasn't very much going on.
But by 1960, 1958, CORE was really doing a lot.
We were doing stores asking for a fair employment.
And banks asking for fair employment at that time in our area where that was predominantly black and Los Angeles around Central Avenue.
And that is Central Los Angeles.
Banks, stores, and other businesses did not hire us except as maintenance people, janitors.
So we picketed them and negotiated with them to hire young people who needed no more than a high school graduate to do what they were doing.
To become salespeople and boxboys.
And we insisted that they trained them for management.
And we were very successful with the grocery stores.
The banks were very reluctant.
But we picketed the banks and negotiated with them.
And finally, they hired tellers and started training people for management.
Who were some of CORE's allies?
I'm sort of interested in what kinds of people worked with you and who CORE worked with.
We were intergratial.
When we went into, well, in 1959, Jesse M. Unruh, who was a representative, passed the bill making accommodations in segregated accommodations illegal.
So we had both blacks and whites in CORE.
And the ACLU, you know, we were friends with people in the ACLU and lawyers and that type of people.
We would go out in our car with suitcases and the children and go to motels and hotels and ask for a room and be denied.
And then the white couple would come after us and get a room.
And so we sued those people.
We would bring suit against them.
And there was a young lawyer who did cases for us pro bono.
And we had success in suing them.
And they would finally change.
Of course, I believe that any law that comes about isn't worth much until it has been tested.
So we set out to test that law and we're successful in breaking down.
I think we did it more quickly than it would have happened if we had not done the test.
Can I ask you what drove you up, Moadabid?
Well, I guess I had always been taught to resist, but we couldn't act overtly.
And we did that with just acting ombley and standing tall and facing these people without being subservient.
And that was instilled in us.
And so when I had the opportunity to act openly, came natural.
Just came natural to do this because I knew it was wrong.
And I made that we were treated.
And when I could do something to prevent it, it was just a normal thing to do.
So jumping around just a little bit, when you started teaching, what year was that that you had your first actual teaching job?
In 1955.
And at that point, how many African Americans were teaching?
Well, quite a few.
Yes, there were quite a few things.
So things had changed?
Things had changed the lot when I started teaching.
Most of the teachers at my school were African Americans, young, very young teachers.
And all of the children were African Americans, maybe one or two who were not.
I can remember one time, a little boy, a white boy was there.
And he got into trouble somehow.
And he was in the vice principal's office.
And the vice principal said to him, you don't have to be here.
I will send you to any school you want to go.
You don't have to be here.
He didn't know I was outside listening.
And this kid, he left.
He left, I don't know where he went.
But those are the kinds of things that you heard.
What was your reaction to that when you heard that?
Well, I just felt that I didn't say anything to him because he had one time told me.
That if I didn't like it here, I should go to another country because I was very active.
And I would put up black people on the wall for the children.
Between Abraham Lincoln and George Washington on Presidents Day, I would put Frederick Douglass, with all his beers.
Tell the children about that.
And I was active.
I was demonstrating then.
And they knew that.
And of course I was wearing my hair natural.
Nobody else was except, I guess, the singer.
Abbey Lincoln, the actress.
And what was her name?
That singer who did folk songs.
It'll come to me.
But we were the only three people that I knew who were doing this.
And it was very disturbing to people for us to begin to do that.
What did that symbolize for you?
Well, I had bets.
For the first time, I met people who had come from Africa.
And we were friends.
And this woman was so beautiful.
And she had her hair short and not pressed just what we call nappy hair.
And I thought how beautiful that was.
And I decided I would cut my hair and wear it like that.
And people wondered why I wanted to do that.
They thought, I don't know.
But that's something.
But I did it.
And my husband was proud.
And sometimes I would go back and straighten it.
And he would say, well, people do it.
You know, you can make, he said, but that's not your hair.
Like that.
And I took his word for it and had done it this way since 1950s.
Wow.
So you were putting up, I just love the image,
you're putting up Frederick Douglass on the wall.
And with George Washington, he really went on Lincoln.
And clearly, trying to teach,
puts in black role models up for the students.
Right.
And I did that.
And I would put out brown paint color for the children to paint themselves.
And that was not popular.
Because they didn't want to think of themselves as black and beautiful.
But one of the most precious moments for me was one time a little girl came
while I was teaching and said to me, she was crying.
Teacher called me black.
And I looked at I said, but you are.
You are black and you are beautiful.
And a few times, a few days later, somebody called him black and I heard her say,
yes, I am.
And I'm beautiful because teacher told me so.
And that was a precious moment.
Precious.
She said it just like, I'm beautiful because teacher told me so.
And sometimes they would come in and I would walk in and knew they would say,
look at teacher's hair.
Look at teacher's hair.
You know, punching one another.
Looks just like mine.
You know?
Made a difference with them.
So can you tell us a little bit about how that led to your writing?
Oh, yes.
At that time, there were very few books that showed us in a positive image.
We had pictures of eating watermelon and red lips and all of that, you know, rings and the nose.
And now Du Bois and Langston Hughes had done some books for children.
But there weren't many.
And I knew a publisher in Los Angeles who did my book, Lillie of Watts.
And I asked him to publish some books for my children, you know, and he said, write them.
If you write them, I'll publish them.
And I said, no, I am not a writer.
And I insisted and I wrote that book and he published it.
And it was reviewed by outstanding reviewers and kind of heady stuff", to be a writer.
But I soon learned after a couple of times that it wasn't that easy.
And I've got a lot of rejection slips.
And then one day I met a young man at Scholastic who had just graduated from Harvard.
He was working there and I had gone in to see a black editor at another place.
And she sent me to see him.
And I went to see him and he took me, that the Harvard had just opened up its restaurant.
It's a place for women to go and eat.
And he took me to go there and that was very nice.
And I told him about a book I wanted to write.
And he said, right, and I wrote a book called The Liquid Trap.
And they thought maybe this was about alcohol.
But it was about these sinkholes in Louisiana, sand traps.
You know, you get caught in the sand.
And I did that book.
And he published it and gave it to, showed it to another editor there.
And she introduced me to a young editor, Barbara Lalicki.
And Barbara was young enough to take a risk with an African American writer.
So she asked me to write a book.
And I wrote Ty's One-Man Band for her.
And that was the very first book on reading Rainbow.
Ty's One-Man Band.
Oh, it was.
Wonderful.
And I stayed with her and wrote most of these books with Barbara.
Were there many African Americans in publishing?
Not editors.
Not publishers, right?
Not publishing, no.
And I think that is the problem.
There are no editors who look at our work and can see and appreciate where we're coming
from.
There are some, of course, there are white editors who do.
But there are no black editors in these major publishing houses.
Not many, not many, not many.
And of course, now we have less than maybe 1% of all the books that are published, written
by, by and for black children.
Maybe less than 1%.
All children's books.
Yeah.
But you were able to connect with some people that understood this.
Oh, yes.
Barbara appreciated what I was doing and had, my first book was a book, not my first, but
my mom needs me was a book about a little boy who, some other had a new baby.
And he was very worried that she didn't love him anymore.
And he went through that.
She went through that with him.
And he would go out and people would want him to do things away from home.
And he said, I can't.
My mom needs me.
He has to get back.
I grew up with my grandchildren.
Oh, really?
Let me see if I can find him.
Yes, yes, yes.
This book was the one.
At first, the illustrator made the character's white.
And my editor showed it to me and I said, no way.
No way.
I could not do that because my purpose was to have our children see themselves.
And I'm sure that's what most black writers wanted.
For the children to see themselves and their families.
And not only for black children, but for all children to see us as we are, you know?
And to know who we are and see us as, now there was one book early that a snowy day by
Jack Keats.
My daughter's favorite book.
See, and that was very nice.
One of the first, he did that to show these children as normal and healthy and really
children.
And all of my books though have a choice, courage and change.
Every character has to make choices and then they have to stand by the choices.
It's a good one.
And if they do, they will grow.
They will change.
And everyone has to do that even here.
My mama needs me.
Right.
Yes.
When you were still teaching, did you ever sort of field test the books with the kids that
you were teaching and bringing your stories to them?
No.
I went around the country with the books.
I wasn't teaching then.
Okay.
I was writing and consulting.
But I would go to schools across the nation and talk to children and read my books and
got wonderful letters from children thanking me and telling me how much they enjoyed knowing
the characters.
So that was quite a pleasant experience to do the books.
And we won some interesting prizes.
Coretta Scott King award for Justin and the Best Biscuits in the World.
And...
You know what's going on?
You might as well play a chord for this work, but I'll have to do it.
This one won the Coretta Scott King award for the Best Book.
And this one won the Christopher Award, Mississippi.
No, not this one.
This one won the Jane Adams, Jane Addams Children's Book Award.
And this one Coretta Scott King, Mississippi Challenge notable book and the Christopher Best
Book award.
They talked a little bit about that book which maybe has a little bit of a, you know,
tardy, maybe a little bit older audience.
Yes, this is for young adults.
And this also is for young adults.
This one is about the slavery doing, the Revolutionary War and Elizabeth "Mum Bett" Freeman winning her
freedom and Massachusetts through the Massachusetts Constitution.
And this one is for young adults about the 1964 and 1968 Mississippi Challenge and all
about Mississippi and how the people in Mississippi had struggled since the beginning of time to
free themselves.
And finally in 1964 they went to the Democratic National Convention in Vanilo, Hamer,
with President Johnson and all of them.
And she had an opportunity to say to them,
it didn't come here to just say do nothing.
We came to take our seats.
And President Johnson promised that they would have a time and then they went back and did
all of that legal work to make possible the seating of their delegate.
And of course I wrote a piece about that for The Big Book for Peace, which said there
can be no peace without justice.
And how they went to Washington and stood waiting for the Congress to decide whether they
would seat them or the white delegation.
They lost that, but they won.
They won.
And it's vital the fact that they were not seated and then they came back and did the work
that made it possible for the Voting Rights Act 1965 to be passed.
And we're really concerned today that the right to vote is in danger here in the 21st
century.
What kind of work do you hope that your writing does?
Well, I hope that it tells children, black and white, all children that they can make
a difference.
And all of my books point that out that you do what you feel is right.
For instance, this book, Alex Premma, this young boy was forced to read by a white girl
in Virginia.
And she told him he could go up to Connecticut.
I think it was Connecticut.
And he would be free.
But he knew better and his mother told him that he must not read because he was a slave.
And he could be sold into away from her.
But she insisted and this girl made him read.
And one day he got very interested in reading.
And one day the grandmother caught him reading.
And she tried to take the book away from him.
It was a Premma.
He wouldn't give it up.
And she hit him in the face with her writing crust.
He still wouldn't give it up.
And his children had that Premma in Connecticut.
So these are the kinds of things that I try to show children, not tell them, but show
them that you make choices.
And you must, if it is a good choice, and a good choice is what is good for all living
things, not just for you, but for all living things.
When you know that is a good choice, then you have
courage.
And courage will help you to stick with that thing.
And you will change.
You will grow.
And all of my characters show that.
And I believe that wholeheartedly, that courage will give us that kind of stick to it in
this, to let us do what is right.
And that is why I was able to do the kinds of things that I did like Nazis"
and go to jail, take that risk.
Because that's what making the choice is.
Choosing is a risk.
I don't want to sound preaching.
No, not at all.
But it is.
That's what choosing is.
It's taking risks.
And when you risk, if you have the courage, because courage is that kind of thing that comes
from being able to listen, listen to your heart.
And not that romantic thing.
That inner spirit that guides you to do what is right.
And you will learn how to go forward or step back at the right moment.
And when you learn that, then you can grow.
You will grow.
You will change.
And as millions of youths say, you won't have status.
You will have status.
So we've talked about your childhood and your work in Los Angeles and with core and teaching
in the books.
How do you see all these things connected?
But I did book reviews for the Los Angeles Times when Johnson made available for them to
bring out more material for multicultural understanding.
And so I read all of those old books that came back from Du Bois and from them.
And I was able to do names there in the camp.
The guy who was in prison in South Africa.
Mandela.
Mandela's book.
I Shall Not Be Moved.
And I reviewed that book for the Los Angeles Times and all of Du Bois' books and James
Baldwin's book.
Well, I didn't review James Baldwin's book.
James Baldwin came to speak for us at core.
He had just written that book that was old.
Go tell it on the map.
No, not that one.
It was the one that talked about Malcolm X and I know the book.
But anyway, he had just written that book.
And the editor at Los Angeles reviewed it and I rebutted his for core.
And I rebutted his review.
And he had said that Baldwin was a bigot in writing this book.
And anyway, I proved from Baldwin's words that he was not because I disagree with some
things with Baldwin.
But I knew he was not a bit because at the end of his book he said, if we, the few that
we are, can bring about, at least we can save this nation.
We can work to save this nation and give it justice.
And after I did that rebuttal, he printed it and he asked me to review books.
Oh, yeah.
Great.
And reviewing books, I decided that's not for me.
I need to write books.
And I just talk about the criticize of the people's work.
Let me try to do something too.
So, but I will tell you some exciting moments in my life that I feel.
Okay.
I marched in housing tracks in Los Angeles.
And we, they were building houses in areas near where a lot of black people lived and
they wouldn't sell them to us.
They wouldn't sell us those houses.
So we pick it that, pick it them.
And I can remember one Saturday we were picketing at a place in what is now Carson, California.
And everything was going well.
We had a big line, a good line and there was a Jewish person, Herbert, who had been in
the concentration camp in Germany.
And he was marching with us.
He had been very active in court.
He went on the freedom rise.
And oh, soon the police came and they came and stood across the street watching us.
And of course, they always brought tension.
But after a while, the tension eased with the police.
And then about four cars drove up full of white men dressed like noxies.
They had on noxie uniform, including the swastika.
And they had on their signs, their sticks were so big that they could have damaged us
with their placards.
And their placards read, ovens too good for Niggas.
Niggas go back to the trees, your monkeys go back to the trees.
And I saw her, but and I was so I got worried about him.
And I wondered if these people would make us lose our stance and become violent.
But we had been trained.
And finally I saw her, but leave the line in a staggering way.
And I wondered, you know, I was very outraged.
And I wondered if I shouldn't leave too, but I stayed and I was questioning myself,
why am I here?
Why am I doing this?
Why do I want people thinking that I want to live beside white people?
Why am I here?
And I, somebody started singing, old freedom.
This lone voice, Oh, Freedom".
And before I be a slave, I'll be bearing in my brain and go home to my Lord and be free.
And I thought, well, I'm not here because I want to live beside white people.
I'm here because I want us to be able to decide where it is we want to live and we can
have the freedom to do that.
And I lost my anger and I felt pleased with myself that I had stayed.
And I was there with not self-ocertiveness, but there and was at peace and was there
a long time after the Noxys had gone home.
And another time I had been asked to go with a group of artists and writers and sculptors
to Nigeria, to the African Festival of Culture, where all people from the diaspora were
coming.
And I was the only children's book writer, so I was able to make a presentation and they
were quite pleased that I had come because they felt that they needed more children's
books on the continent.
But anyway, I stayed after Nigeria.
I went to Ghana and to other places, Cameroon and to Ghana and looked around.
And I felt in many instances in Ghana, especially, they looked at me and they wanted to know
who is that woman.
She was a woman in the market where I was and somebody said she's a cacuey woman.
She's a cacuey woman.
They said no, I don't think she's cacuey.
She might be a chola.
And at that time I spoke to another lady who was not with them.
And when they heard my voice, they said oh my god, she's a white woman.
Oh, so you can imagine how I felt.
And it's amazing, I don't like to think of that.
But I can remember one time when I was a teenager, I was a freshman in college and walking
down the street in Louisiana and soldiers were out there, were there.
And a white soldier called to his friends and the drugstore and said hey, come see this
pretty nigger.
And for some reason I got that same feeling there.
And I don't know why, but when they said oh my god, she's a white woman.
She's not one of us.
And that's what they were implying.
So I went, I knew a great poet there, Kofi Awoonor,
And he was gracious to take me to Elmina Castle, that castle.
And we went to that and I listened to the people, this young man talk about the people who
had been in there.
And he was like a person who had no, his voice was like people doing an ad on TV, no way
of connecting.
And at that time we walked up on the deck to see the guns and the door of no return.
And when we walked up there and hear word these men in chains.
And at first I thought my god, I'm hallucinating, something.
It was a prison at that time.
It was a prison.
But so many of us have gone there, they have understand that it's no longer so.
So Kofi and I went and stood on the, he wanted me to see the, those big guns that were
trained on the ships.
So that when the slaves were about to leave, there could be no interference.
And we went on the Atlantic Ocean and walked on the beach and I was looking up at those
guns and listening to the sound of the ocean rolling up.
And ocean waves always remind me of the blues for some reason.
And I stood there and I looked up at those guns and I thought.
I am not African and I am not American.
We had not been allowed to carry the flag at the festival.
And I am not protected under the flag of my country.
And I broke down and cried.
And Kofi said, what is it with your Americans?
You, one of you who come here, you do that.
And I couldn't tell him why.
But I knew that I'm not African really and I'm not American.
But I have a heritage of Africa and I'm born in America so I can take the best of both
cultures and be who I am.
And I can become whole.
I do not.
I am not a three fifths of a person.
And I thought that there.
I'm not three fifths of a person as the Constitution says on the shores of Africa.
I felt this.
I am not a potential.
I am.
And my blackness is not a lack.
It is.
And I felt that I am unique, unique.
Neither one or the other.
And I can understand why Africa does not really know us.
It's too painful.
We were brutally taken away.
Never heard of again.
Nobody ever returned.
And the pain is so great you have to suppress that pain and forget.
Forget.
And now we're going back and they are beginning to see.
We are very much a part of them.
Very much.
And of course I came back thinking I'm unique but when I came back I couldn't talk about
that to anybody.
They might think I'm being arrogant and not wanting to identify with my African heritage.
And so I didn't say I didn't talk about it.
But I figured not knowing and I didn't know enough about Africa.
Three months in Africa tells you nothing.
I didn't know enough.
But what I could do, I could begin to find out more about my heritage and about my
people, where they had come from.
And I did.
My grandmother came from Guinea and she was part of the French and ended up in Haiti.
And from Haiti after the French, the Toussaint L'Ouverture Revolution ended up in Louisiana.
And I can find out more and become fully whole.
And I think I've done that.
I have looked at African religions, looked at Christian religion and philosophies and
all of that.
And I think I can see comparisons between Jesus and my people.
And that is why we were able to turn the other cheek and walk the second mile.
Yes, yes.
And I feel that if we can finally really have a discourse about race in this country as
the South Africans did for reconciliation, we will become healed.
It would be a healing.
The Kerner Commission recognized that we needed to really look at the problem of racism,
and discuss it, but the Kerner Commission was denied.
And we fell back into the old ways of doing things.
And until we can make that reconciliation, we will not be healed.
What do you think it's going to take?
It's going to take acknowledging it.
He as the people who were oppressed and those people who are the relatives and the generations
of the oppressors, we are going to have to sit down together and really discuss this and
acknowledge the pain.
Because I'm sure that there is pain on both sides.
You cannot murder, you cannot mistreat, you cannot oppress and not feel guilt.
And guilt is very damaging.
And you cannot be treated that way without feeling anger.
And anger is very damaging.
And we must come together and discuss this, this fear that they feel.
There is so much fear of us, and we sense that.
There's fear, there's guilt, and as anger, and there is humility and wanting and longing
on both sides.
I have gone to films and I have seen people who have, who are the relatives of those who
were oppressors, mentioned that when they know their relatives, when they find out that
their relatives were doing this, they couldn't walk out of their house for days.
They were so depressed and they couldn't talk about it.
You see, there's nobody who would understand, nobody who's willing to listen.
And we are going to have to, I think, come to this reconciliation if we are to become
a whole and not be so afraid that we have to wage wars, have soldiers everywhere.
Right.
That's right.
They did it in South Africa, they did it in Australia.
But we cannot do it.
We tried it in Greensboro Truth and Reconciliation Commission 2004-06.
I don't know if you followed that.
Yeah.
I mean, so there have been attempts.
There have been attempts.
And I just hope we can.
Of course, I traveled and went to the Soviet Union on a piece mark.
That's right.
Yeah.
What was that?
Well, we were there.
Every town that we went into, we walked from one place to Moscow.
And every place we knew place we went into, they'd bring out this huge, round loaf of bread
and salt.
And each person would break bread.
And as we broke bread and ate, shared that bread, we broke barriers.
And while I was there, I began to understand why we were not allowed to eat in restaurants
and would sit with families to eat.
It breaks barriers.
Breaking bread breaks barriers.
And there we broke the barriers and we did not remain strangers or the other.
We were able to really discuss and need and get along.
This very basic, very ancient level.
Yes.
And we talked about the need for peace and to do away with atomic bombs, nuclear weapons.
And while I was there, I was given the Coretta Scott King Award for this book.
And I sent a letter for acceptance in my editor, Reddit.
And that letter said, I had to make a choice.
Did I go on this walk?
Would I stay and go to San Francisco and receive that Honorable Award?
And then I thought about the Coretta Scott King Award.
And what the children would think.
And I thought they would appreciate it if I walked for peace rather than go.
And I made the choice to walk for peace rather than come to the acceptance.
So maybe we can end with this question then connecting to that.
You work in the movement and then we talk about reconciliation and peace.
How do you connect all of these pieces?
I do feel that there can be no peace without justice.
And all of the efforts that we made in the 60s, especially throughout our history,
we didn't just start working for freedom in the 60s.
And it was just not Martin Luther King and Fannie Lou Hamer and Rosa Parks.
It was a lot of young, energetic people and leaders who were killed and who were named and bombed.
So I do feel that these people who can do this and really change are those who can listen,
really know how to listen and listen, not thinking about what they are going to say against
the person who is talking.
But listen and come to an understanding that we are all, we are all one, one.
And that we must work together to bring peace to our own lives, to the lives of others,
to this nation, to the world.
And when we really know this, when we know it, we will do it.
We will do it when we know it.
And all the great thinkers have said that.
When you know a thing, you will do it.
Howard Thurman was one of those, stress that.
Know it and do it.
And I feel that is what has kept me with the faith, to try, to bring about a message that
fits our time.
All down the history, gospels have changed, to fit the time and the need of the people.
And we need that now.
It's ongoing, it's ongoing work.
It's on Christianity is an ongoing, it's ongoing.
It is not steady, it is not to be accepted or rejected.
It is to be carried on, to bring about and serve the needs of our time.
And I think that I wish I was 20 years younger.
But I'm not.
And I feel that my time is not there.
What can I ask how old you are today?
I'm 90 years old, this past September, 1970, over the November, 1970, where I was.
And six months, 90 years old and six months.
So you can see I don't have too much, all things being equal.
All things being equal.
Yeah, more books.
I was going to say moving and fighting.
I wish I could get a memoir published, but it's hard now.
They want stuff from celebrities.
But you've done so, so much.
And we're so grateful for sharing the story with us today.
Well, I am so grateful for you to listen to my story.
I am.
I feel blessed.
And I feel honored.
As do we.
Thank you.
Any last thing you'd like to say before we wrap up?
So it's just beautiful.
I would just like to acknowledge my children.
I have two sons.
I had a son to pass away in 2008.
He had worked very hard in the Black Studies Department at California State University, Los Angeles.
And he had done some books for young men.
And I have my younger son is living in Santa Monica, California.
And he works for the City College there.
He did films then.
But I am very proud of my children.
And my grandson, whose children you saw, has been very reliable.
And he takes good care and see to it that I'm okay.
This is why you came back to California to be a good kid.
That's why I came back.
And he invited me along with his wife who met and his children.
So that I feel blessed.
Lots of friends and acquaintances.
Oh, there was one thing I didn't talk about.
In 1970.
I worked with a group of people of color nurses.
And we started that name, people of color, rather than minorities.
We did work in the schools of nurses.
At the time when we were doing this work to bring culture, we wanted to get them to
know and appreciate the cultures of people of color, which would be helpful in making
diagnosis.
At that time when they diagnosed shock, synonyms and inflammation, they used red, white, and
blue.
And a lot of us died in shock because we could not turn white.
We could not turn red.
We could not turn blue.
And so we worked on that.
And these nurses gave indications of how to determine that.
And we also, at that time, you could go to visit your people in the hospital between
two and four.
And we couldn't go because we were working.
And then they had one set of one menu and a lot of the food that they gave we didn't
like.
And people of color didn't eat that kind of food.
And there was another thing that we did too.
We had it so that doing transition at one time, you couldn't bring children for the end of
that period.
Now the whole family, we talked about how necessary that was for people of color.
And now anybody, or everybody, when doing transition, they provide a room where you can go and
be with that patient during that period.
Asian people were suffering from dehydration because at one time they would just put ice
water on the table and expect people to drink the ice water.
They didn't drink ice water.
There were so few nurses of Native American.
We couldn't get a statistic.
So now, because of this, we added all of this into the text books for nurses and made
all those changes.
And now we are very pleased that the term, People of Color, is much more common uses than
minorities.
So I did the culture of African Americans.
I did the African American culture part for consulted with the nurses and did that part.
And that was in the 1970s.
The Western Interstate Commission for Higher Education sponsored that project.
And Dr. Dr. Marie F. Branch was the major nurse who had it this project.
Oh, glad you mentioned that.
Oh, I did too.
Very important.
I agree all I thought was for the firm kids.
Yeah, I didn't.
Yes, that was the, we thought minority is insulting.
You are minority less.
"Peoples of Color define us accurately.
Asians, African Americans, Chinese Native Americans.
We all work together on that project.
Wonderful.
Well, let me just thank you one more time.
This was just such a treat for us and such an honor.
Well, I put out strawberries and grapes and cookies.
We will take advantage of your hospitality.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.